en el vídeo pasado empezamos a platicar
un poco acerca de cómo poder financiar
un negocio desde el principio así desde
que uno tiene la idea déjame irme para
acá arriba estábamos platicando de cómo
a mis amigos y a mí se nos ocurrió una
idea de vender calcetines por internet y
dijimos bueno ya tenemos esta idea
nuestro talento tenemos que venderle
esta idea a alguien para que nos pueda
financiar y recurrimos al mercado de
capital en específico nos enfocamos al
capital de riesgo porque ahí es donde se
obtiene capital para empezar negocios y
más aún nos fuimos con un inversionista
ángel porque eran esta figura de tío
millonario que dan dinero así para
muchos inversionistas jóvenes que tienen
pues ideas emprendedoras de tecnología
de la información que se ven
prometedoras y que se ve pues que
podrían regresar algún retorno entonces
fuimos con un capitalista de riesgo un
inversionista ángel en este caso y él
pues dijo baja los voy a apoyar pero
tenemos que hacer algunas negociaciones
para estas negociaciones tuvimos que
hacer una evaluación previa en la cual
ambos quedamos de acuerdo
dijimos va a esta es la evaluación
previa que nos interesa los dos y con
eso el inversionista ángel luego decidió
5 millones de pesos en efectivo para
poder financiar la idea y comenzar a
rentar un local que pudiéramos pagar los
salarios para dejar nuestros trabajos y
pues hacer todo el tipo de cosas que uno
hace cuando cuando ya quiere empezar a
hacer un negocio no una vez que nos dio
el dinero
tuvimos que emitir las acciones nosotros
como mesa directiva con eso él forma
parte de esta nueva mesa directiva bueno
no inmediatamente pero ya teniendo un
millón de acciones pues ya puede ponerse
prácticamente en la meta directiva y
bueno ya todos estamos felices porque
podíamos empezar a trabajar con el
efectivo y cada quien tenía su capital
correspondiente
esto nos daba una evaluación posterior y
calculamos algunos porcentajes pero
habla había dos cosas de las cuales
teníamos que platicar una ya la
practicamos que es este fenómeno de
dilución de dinero y ya vimos que
realmente en el fondo nos disminuye el
valor de lo que poseemos pero por otro
lado te iba a comentar qué sucede si el
inversionista ángel es más rudo así si
quiere pues hacer una negociación un
poco más conveniente para él para esto
déjame pensar en la siguiente situación
supongamos y lo voy a escribir aquí
jamás déjame déjame ponerlo en un
cuadrito bueno lo voy a hacer y luego lo
me lo meten en cuadritos supongamos que
otra vez tenemos aquí la idea la voy a
poner un poquito más abajo
la idea
pero ahora el inversionista ángel no
dice sabes que yo creo que tu idea vale
5 millones si no dicen sabes que chin o
sea yo creo que tu idea de los
calcetines no va a pegar también o es
algo muy experimental yo nomás voy a
decir que vale un millón e imaginemos
que nosotros como pues así gente
emprendedora dice chin bueno no nos
conviene tanto pero la situación
económica está tan fea y queremos éste
renunciar tanto de nuestros trabajos que
van que vamos a aceptar que vale un
millón ahora como el ángel puso cinco
millones porque era lo que se necesitaba
para empezar la empresa de todas formas
ahorita también va a tener que poner 5
millones lo voy a hacer más o menos
proporcional
entonces otra vez va a tener que tener
que poner 5 millones de pesos en
efectivo para realizar las operaciones
del negocio y entonces ahora qué va a
suceder con el lado derecho de la hoja
de balance pues una vez más aquí abajito
había un millón de acciones que nosotros
ya habíamos emitido me voy a poner por
aquí que son un millón de acciones y por
ahí está este mi parte que te digo que
me gusta mucho
e indicar la parte que son 200.000
acciones entonces ahora nosotros pusimos
algo que vale un millón el inversionista
puso algo que vale 5 millones y entonces
cuánto tendríamos que darle pues ve mira
vamos a vamos a hacer un poquito de
numeritos para ver qué sucedía aquí
antes a ver antes que teníamos ya
teníamos una evaluación previa
aquí la evaluación previa va a cambiar
verdad ya la la idea ya no va a valer
cinco millones sino un millón pero qué
sucede entonces ahora aquí tenemos que
cada quien tenía 200 mil acciones
digamos en esta situación ya teníamos
una variación previa y una evaluación
posterior
la variación posterioridad de 10
millones así que al final de cuentas
cada quien tenía pues de estos 10
millones una décima parte bueno cada
quien de nosotros una décima parte o sea
algo equivalente a un millón cada uno de
nosotros cinco de pesos verdad
equivalente un millón de pesos un millón
y el inversionista al que él tenía algo
equivalente a cinco millones de pesos
entonces acá pues mira son 200.000
acciones por algo que vale un millón y
entonces cuál es el precio por acción
déjame ponerle por aquí en algún lugar
precio por acción precio por acción y
aquí pues cómo estaban las cosas o sea
esta idea valía 5 millones de pesos y
eran un millón de acciones entonces aquí
el precio por acción era de 5 pesos van
5 pesos
bueno ya le puse el signo de pesos nada
más le voy a dejar el signo
5 pero qué sucede acá ahora acá hay un
millón de pesos en y de ahí hay un
millón de acciones entonces aquí tenemos
un precio por acción precio por acción
de de un peso y entonces cuando él pone
5 millones de pesos cuando el
inversionista pone 5 millones de pesos
para iniciar las operaciones del negocio
entonces vamos a tener que emitir le
pues le equivalente en acciones que como
son de a peso para ser 5 millones de
acciones van
lleva a poner 5 millones de acciones
bueno no va a poner así vale pesos no
acciones
acciones van entonces un millón de
acciones de nosotros cinco millones de
él aparte de las nuestras están
divididas en cinco cachitos verdad vamos
a ver qué pasa con el fenómeno de
dilución de dinero a ver si si por acá
también bueno se da esto de que se
diluye fíjate acá teníamos que cada
quien tenía 200 mil en acciones entonces
aquí teníamos pues un quinto verdad de
toda la compañía y un quinto de toda la
compañía era algo equivalente a un
millón
y acá también era algo equivalente a un
millón entonces de un millón a un millón
no se diluyó qué sucede en este caso
vámonos a la evaluación previa
evaluación previa
entonces ahora aquí que sucede pues
ahora teníamos otra vez es un quinto de
un millón bueno ahora es un millón
verdad entonces ahora en la evaluación
previa cada quien tiene algo equivalente
a 200 mil pesos doscientos mil pesos y
qué pasa en la evaluación posterior pues
en la evaluación posterior ahora el
total de la empresa es de 6 millones de
pesos verdad y de lo cual nosotros
tienen tenemos nada más un cachito
déjame ver cuántos serían
a ver ahora en la evaluación posterior
en total hay 6 millones o hay 6 millones
en acciones pero cada uno de nosotros
solo tiene 200.000 entonces déjame hacer
algunas cuentas por acá entonces tenemos
200.000 de 6000
acción es esto de aquí es se cancelan
los 0 2 bueno a 200.000 de seis mil
millones o sea de 6.000 miles más de
seis millones entonces aquí nos queda
uno sobre treinta cada uno de nosotros
somos dueños de una 30 aparte de la
empresa y una de 30 va parte de 6
millones 130 va parte de 6 millones es
igual a un quinto de millón el 30 entre
65 y un quinto de millón es igual a 200
mil pesos entonces observa que de todas
formas este fenómeno de dilución no se
da
entonces de 200.000 pasamos a tener
200.000 pero en qué radica esto de la
negociación con el ángel en qué radica
su importancia pues ve antes en este
caso de acá el inversionista ángel lo
voy a poner así el ángel
tenía el 50% de la empresa y nosotros el
otro 50% pero en este caso de acá ahora
el ángel ángel tiene pues cinco sextas
partes de la empresa y nosotros sólo
tenemos una sexta parte para pensar un
poquito en términos porcentuales esto es
pues más o menos le va a poner
aproximadamente igual y aproximadamente
igual como a 84 por ciento y a 16 por
ciento entonces la importancia de
negociar en esta etapa inicial consiste
pues en el porcentaje que van a tener
cada una de las partes de la empresa
bueno estar acá era una situación
imaginaria que dije que le iba a poner
en un cuadro lo voy a poner así un
cuadro color rosa mexicano algo de este
estilo entonces esta es la situación
hipotética en la cual el inversionista
es muy muy difícil de tratar y nos dice
que nuestra idea vale muy poquito vale
pero ahorita nos vamos a quedar con esta
idea con la de la izquierda en la cual
nuestra idea vale la mitad de toda la
compañía después de la de la evaluación
después del dinero va entonces déjame
volver a
a regresar esta situación que es la
situación que está padre la situación
positiva y la voy a reflejar otra vez
dibujando una hoja de balance si este no
es el color que quería la voy a dibujar
con la hoja de balance
entonces aquí tenemos la idea
y luego sobre la idea el inversionista
ángel puso va a ponerlo con este color
sobre la idea el inversionista puso
efectivo
voy a ponerle déjame indicarlo así
porque ahorita vamos a rayar tantito
efectivo y del lado derecho de esta el
capital de todos más capital
voy a ponerle estar allí está para
indicar que estoy acá desde el ángel
ángel existe el capital
y esto de acá es de nosotros que está
dividido en cinco cachitos pero déjame
otra vez marcar mi parte por acá que son
200.000 acciones
bueno entonces ahora sí ya estamos en
esta situación tenemos el efectivo pero
pues no conseguimos efectivo nada más
para aventar lo por los aires verdad y
para nadar en albercas de billetes lo
que queríamos hacer desde el principio
es empezar una empresa de calcetines por
internet y entonces ya con el efectivo
podemos hacer eso supongamos que de los
cinco millones empezamos a gastar a
alquilar un lugar nos compramos una mesa
de futbolito contratamos a varias
personas de limpieza a los de los
diseñadores web y que vamos gastando y
gastando efectivo hasta que nos gastamos
todo esto de acá ya le voy a indicar
aquí
que nos gastamos 4 millones de pesos ya
en todo ya nada más nos queda un millón
de pesos en efectivo va entonces un
millón en efectivo pero ahora estoy acá
que ya no es efectivo ya se convirtieron
en otro bueno ya se convirtió en otro
tipo de activos ahora ya tenemos una
oficina oficina tenemos un sitio en
internet tenemos pues a lo mejor la mesa
de futbolito la mesa de de futbolito
etcétera entonces ya tenemos activos
para poder realizar este nuestro nuestro
negocio y tenemos un millón en efectivo
para poder ir pagando los salarios sin
embargo ya nos preocupa un poco esta
situación porque ya es poco efectivo
comparado con las operaciones que
tenemos que hacer sobre todo porque ya
contratamos a 40 personas entonces a lo
mejor debemos de empezar pensando a
empezar a pensar en una nueva ronda de
financiamiento entonces ahora lo que
tenemos que hacer es conseguir más
dinero para pues ya sabes tenemos que
hacer publicidad tenemos que hacer otras
cosas verdad lo mejor ahora sí abrir una
pues no se unan a una fábrica de
calcetines o algo así entonces tenemos
que recurrir a más dinero ahora no no
podemos ir otra vez con inversionistas
ángeles déjame para acá arriba porque
los inversionistas ángeles otra vez solo
apoyan a ideas que acaban de empezar así
de la nada entonces ya no podemos ir ahí
porque ya tenemos un inversionista ángel
que nos apoyó para empezar entonces
tenemos que recurrir a otra parte a otro
a otro tipo de mercado de capital dentro
del capital de riesgo que ya son
capitalistas de riesgo profesionales
profesionales
y en esta primera ronda de capitalistas
de riesgo profesionales nos vamos a
enfocar en los capitalistas de riesgo
semilla semilla
entonces al inversionista ángel lo
logramos cautivar con nuestro carisma
con nuestras ideas y pues él estaba
también entusiasmado por nuestro
proyecto pero ahora este capitalista de
riesgo semilla déjame moverme para acá
abajo para tener un poco más de espacio
pero ahora este capitalista de riesgo
semilla le voy a poner aquí semilla hay
varios términos para referirse a a un
capitalista de este estilo vamos a
decirle semilla estos capitalistas de
riesgo semilla ya no son como los
inversionistas ángeles de que se
entusiasman por cualquier cosa esto sí
acá ya son profesionales y en
administrar dinero y no es su dinero es
dinero de otras personas que consiguen a
través pues tal vez de fondos de
cobertura o cosas por el estilo entonces
ellos ya pues son mucho más
especialistas en esto de invertir tienen
un grupo de analistas que tienen
maestrías en administración de negocios
que hacen proyecciones y hojas de
cálculo entonces él pues ya es un
negociador más difícil ya va a ser un
poco más complicado llegar a alguna
evaluación que nos convenga a todos pero
tiene algunas ventajas o sea una vez que
conseguimos el apoyo de un capitalista
de riesgo semilla o valla de cualquier
capitalista
pues el como ya es experto en estas
cosas tiene contactos y nos puede
contactar con alguna fábrica con algunos
diseñadores internacionales además es
bueno administrando administrando
negocios tiene idea de que tips nos
puede dar de qué cosas pueden servir
para nuestra compañía y entonces la cosa
ahora consiste en convencer a un
capitalista de riesgo semilla y decirle
sabes que mira ya estamos en esta etapa
del negocio en la cual ya tenemos un
sitio una oficina y vamos avanzando le
pero necesitamos más dinero para un
comercial en la final de fútbol o
necesitamos más dinero para empezar a
comprar telas o lo que sea y entonces el
capitalista de riesgo puede decir ahora
sí bueno vale entonces vamos a invertir
le íbamos a todos ganar bueno déjame
ponerle un término esto de acá en el
siguiente vídeo vamos a hacerlo más
concretamente pero a esta ronda de
financiamiento en la cual ya entramos
con los capitalistas de riesgo le vamos
a llamar la serie
la serie y entonces de la primera serie
formal con un capitalista de riesgo
profesional y así también podríamos
tener la seriedad y luego la serie b y
serie c y si somos muy certeros con
nuestra empresa de calcetines puede que
lleguemos a una oferta pública oferta
pública
en la bolsa de valores y esto sería
súper padre pero bueno ahorita no me
quiero adelantar mucho en el siguiente
vídeo vamos a platicar de estas otras
rondas de financiamiento y hasta la
próxima